hi there today is day 39 getting closer
to that halfway point I've got a bit of
a flu today was not such an active
Korean learning day you know in language
learning
once you start down a path he'd tend to
follow in that path so yesterday I
started listening to articles on a
chemistry about the situation in the
Ukraine and there's so many over the
last few days that I spent I guess must
have been three or four hours today
listening to and reading articles in on
economically and also looking up
information on Wikipedia and elsewhere
by the way Wikipedia I'm going to donate
money to Wikipedia I have been critical
of them in the past because they'd
rather arbitrarily decided that link
couldn't have a little stub on Wikipedia
whereas you know link whoever else
Rosetta Stone did but I think it's very
good the way everyone who posts an
article there can expect that article to
be criticized you know reviewed added to
amended and I think the net result is
actually quite good information in many
ways better certainly than the average
newspaper article or even quote peer
reviewed academic treatise where there's
far more slanted opinions and they're
remarkably quick at updating itself good
for them and there's a lot of useful
information and I will do a separate
video on this whole Ukrainian situation
which i think is extremely important to
the world
however today but I did manage to do in
my Korean as much as I was motivated to
learn more and more about the Ukrainian
situation which I didn't really
understand I still tore myself away from
it to get in some Korean because you
have to do some everyday at least in
something like this challenge where I'm
trying to get my intensity level up I
want to do something every day so I went
through a few articles on link both on
the computer and on the iPad but a
little bit tired with the flu and
yesterday I had a conversation with one
of our career tutors of link and I got
all my endings mangled
you know and I particularly thought with
it with the way they expressed the
negative in Korean and so I went back to
this book which was my Japanese book on
Korean grammar and it's divided up into
sections and there is a section on the
negative so I went in and they have with
so many examples there they're you know
they're limited in terms of explanations
just example so there's very there's so
many different ways in Korean to express
the negative
I went over those so I did a bit of that
review haven't done a lot of listening
might have got an hour and a half in if
I feel up to it I might do a little more
Korea after dinner so basically that's
it you know as I've said before on the
one hand if I just continue my nesting
and reading of course my speaking
suffers tomorrow for example I'm
speaking with Julien at 10 o'clock I was
gonna and I think I still will video it
and show you whether I've made progress
or not since the last time but when we
speak like when I was speaking to the
editor at the German u-boat when we're
concentrating on communicating and we're
not thinking so much about trying to get
this writer that right we actually do
better once I start thinking about how
do i form that negative then all of a
sudden I get tongue-tied and I can't do
it
and of course that bothers me but I know
from experience if I just kept listening
and reading I'd eventually get better
and I'd accumulate more vocabulary so
there's part of me that says forget it
just continue listening and reading you
you'll eventually get there but then I
say tomorrow I'm I'm gonna be talking to
Julie hyung so I want to review my you
know get back in the book and review it
whether that helps me not I'm not
entirely sure it might make me more
self-conscious and I'll end up doing
more 40 I don't know anyway that's a
brief description of what my day was
like today on day 39 bye for now